I do microblade my eyebrows the last
time I did it was in Dairy Ireland my
lipstick I've worn for years I don't
ever change it do you care this much I'm
really going into it Courtney Cox
reveals her beauty secrets thanks a lot
okay and figures regrets you look in the
mirror and go oh oh that looks good you
think and you don't realize what it
looks like to the outside person I think
I messed up a lot it's the one where the
friend star opens up about her routine
on the Los Angeles Beauty podcast I curl
my lashes every day I think that's an
important thing for me and I use pretty
much any kind I use voluminous mascara
Court then details the procedure she
wishes she didn't do I think I was
getting older when I was really young
that's just a bummer a wasted time it's
a domino effect it's like you don't
realize that you look a little off so
then you keep doing more because you
look normal to yourself and you look in
the mirror and go oh that looks good you
think and you don't realize what it
looks like to the outside person and
just doing too many fillers it's the
first time she dished about her lip
filler regret in 2017 Court told new
Beauty she found it harder getting older
especially in Hollywood she was trying
so hard to keep up and made things worse
but after going to multiple doctors she
pivoted and finally got them removed
which thank God they are removable but I
think I've messed I messed up a lot and
now luckily I can you know I was able to
reverse most of that now I'm actually
just older Courtney told the Mad quote
I'm asking natural as I can be I feel
better because I look like myself I
think that I now look more like the
person that I was I hope I do
[Music]